some homeowners concerned over their
safety after a suspected burglar was
shot and killed in Henderson thank you
for joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce
and I'm Brian Loftus they tell us this
wasn't the first time a burglary
happened on their street the attempted
theft happened near Sun City Anthem
drive and volunteer Boulevard that's
where Joshua paguera Joins us live with
the latest Joshua
Kirsten Bryant I spoke with several
homeowners on this block fearful to go
on camera saying they don't want to be
the next Target of a burglary but they
say they're doing what they can to stay
safe
Henderson Police say on Thursday March
2nd a man stopped to check on his
deceased dad's home he found a burglar
inside the 61 year old shot and killed
the Intruder the coroner's office
identified him as 38 year old Dylan Gall
he was shot in the guest bedroom and
died in the kitchen Henderson Police
saying the sun will not face charges
records show the 93-year-old homeowner
died February 14th last Wednesday
neighbors say that same home had been
burglarized Jonathan Alvarez with Crime
Stoppers of Nevada says homeowners need
to be proactive in protecting themselves
we always support having an alarm system
with some sort of response that could
notify you on your phone if there's any
intrusion Alvarez also recommends making
sure windows are locked keeping the area
around your home well lit and knowing
your neighbors the goal is to make it as
difficult as possible for criminals to
get inside and sometimes people you know
Overlook some of the smallest aspects so
much so is locking the front door or
locking the garage door
tell me homes on this block have been
targeted by burglars in the past year
reporting live in a Sun City Anthem and
volunteer Joshua progero 8 News Now